[Música]
es un pueblo aislado en medio de la
selva tropical del norte de República
democrática del Congo entre las casas de
Barros se encuentra la iglesia de San
Emilio entre 1992 y 2001 un sacerdote
esloveno ofició Allí se llamaba josep
apodado José por los habitantes
Pía tenía entonces 14 años era uno de
sus monaguillos josef lo invitaba
regularmente a su casa después de la
misa
nosotros nadie
campea acá
exacta exacta Sofía
el padre Joseph supuestamente agredió a
decenas de hombres todos ellos menores
de edad en ese momento algunos de ellos
también mencionan el sexo con
penetración John Denisse tenía 16 años
no sobornaba con una pequeña cantidad de
dinero para que no dijéramos nada
le conoces esa era ropa a veces jabón
también contribuye a mis estudios me
daba dinero para ir a la escuela
al igual que John Denise varios jóvenes
han podido estudiar en la ciudad vecinas
de en bandaca y vicoro gracias a la
ayuda económica del padre Joseph en el
pueblo muchos ancianos apreciaron la
generosidad del sacerdote pero en ese
momento se desconocían los abusos
ayuda a los monaguillos con dinero para
los estudios los jóvenes le ayudaban en
la misa y lo acompañaban por el pueblo
supe lo que había pasado cuando los
chicos empezaron a hablar pero antes no
había visto nada
en 2001 dos presuntas víctimas
denunciaron al padre Joseph el sacerdote
fue acusado por la policía judicial de
pederastia atentado al pudor y atentado
a la seguridad del estado al ser
interrogado niega todas las acusaciones
Pero esto es lo que concluye la policía
local al final de su informe las
acusaciones contra el padre José son
fundadas en la medida en que tiene una
relación particular con estos jóvenes
fuera de la comunidad el padre josef
nunca ha sido llamado ante un juez en la
rdc según este antiguo sacerdote la
congregación las Arista a cargo de la
parroquia de moto dio la orden de que se
le devolviera a Europa lo antes posible
el provincial vino a pedirme si podía
hacer un movimiento hacia mututo
alegra un control encontrarme con el
hermano José para que a las 3 de la
mañana pudiera sacarlo a boba banda
no podía ni siquiera en quien fue
evacuado rápidamente
al ser contactada la congregación
declaró que el sacerdote no era miembro
de la orden y negó cualquier vínculo con
el padre Joseph en 2021 el padre de una
de las presuntas víctimas reabre el caso
a petición suya la policía judicial
conguleña entrevistó a varias presuntas
víctimas y a sus familiares la policía
volvió a concluir que el padre Joseph
debía ser llevado ante un juez 20 años
después
hicimos esta declaración en 2021 porque
hasta ahora nadie nos ha ayudado el cura
está lejos Así que era complicado dar
los pasos desde aquí en mi testimonio
pido que el estado haga su trabajo con
esta historia hemos perdido a nuestro
hermano
el año pasado 11 presuntas víctimas
también recurrieron a una ong Open
International para que la representara
está transmitiendo al Vaticano sus
testimonios así como los varios testigos
y familiares de víctimas fallecidas la
arquidiócesis de mandaka no quiso
concedernos una entrevista pero nos
envió un comunicado de prensa en agosto
revela que la arquidiócesis llevó a cabo
una investigación bajo la supervisión
del dicasterio para la doctrina de la fe
al concluir la investigación después
evaluar todas las pruebas se Consideró
que no hay elementos que impliquen la
culpabilidad del acusado no se nos ha
facilitado más información sobre la
investigación la arquidiócesis de
bandaka la nunciatura en kinshasa y el
dicasterio para la doctrina de la fe no
respondieron a nuestras preguntas pero
varias presuntas víctimas algunas de las
cuales había escrito El Vaticano nos
dijeron que no habían sido escuchadas
por la iglesia es el caso de Michelle
se esperaba que al ocurrir así
la gente pudiera acercarse a nosotros
que éramos los Testigos presenciales
Para obtener más información pero nadie
lo hizo
para las personas que se negaron que no
el señor no tiene la culpa
también me gustaría enfrentarme a estas
personas estoy dispuesto para
la ong International la gestión de este
caso demuestra los fallos en la lucha
contra los abusos sexuales en la iglesia
el hecho de que no se haya entrevistado
a todas las víctimas refleja la forma en
que se tratan los abusos sexuales a
menores y otros tipos de abusos en todo
el mundo
pocos países sobre todo los que están en
vías de desarrollo disponen de
procedimientos para proteger a las
víctimas
a principios de 2022 una periodista
eslovena Nobita mihanovic encontró al
padre Joseph en un artículo publicado en
la portada del periódico delo reveló que
el obispado esloveno había presentado
una denuncia civil por abuso sexual de
menores pero que el procedimiento se
había archivado por haber pasado la
fecha de vencimiento el padre josef
oficia ahora en la parroquia de slipnica
en su país de origen se negó a darnos
una entrevista las fotos publicadas en
su cuenta de Facebook y en las redes
sociales de la parroquia lo muestran
posando con niños la arquidiócesis de
maribor a la que pertenece dice que
apoyaría a las víctimas según los
resultados de la investigación congoleña